Welcome to SmartLess with Jason Bateman, Sean Hayes, and me, Will Arnett. Each week, one of us brings on a special guest and surprises the other two. They don't know who the guest is, which makes it fun. And then we laugh and we get a little less smart less. So I guess more smarter. More smarter. We should have needed more smarter. Anyway, come take a ride on the SmartLess train.
欢迎来到《SmartLess》，我是杰森·贝特曼、肖恩·海耶斯，还有我，威尔·阿奈特。每周，我们中的一人会请来一位特别嘉宾，给另外两人一个惊喜。他们不知道嘉宾是谁，这很有趣。然后我们开怀大笑，变得没那么“没头脑”了。所以我猜是变得更聪明了。更聪明。我们本该需要更聪明一点。总之，快来搭上《SmartLess》这趟列车吧。
Will, you just, congratulations. You just had a baby. That's pretty amazing. It should be noted, my partner had a baby, I was, I didn't do it. But you pushed just as hard. I sure did. I pushed her. Yeah.
威尔，恭喜你。你刚有了个孩子。这太棒了。需要说明的是，是我伴侣生的孩子，我，我没生。但你推得一样用力。我确实推了。我推了她。是的。
I was like, what are you made of? I was like the great Santini in the delivery room. Yeah. Yeah. I just had a baby boy, little Denny. That's incredible. Just last night. Yeah.
我当时想，你是什么做的？我在产房里就像《伟大的桑蒂尼》里的角色一样。是的。是的。我刚生了个男婴，小丹尼。太不可思议了。就在昨晚。是的。
So crazy. Do I look tired? You do. So way to, way to, way to hang in there with your girl. So you just thought you'd pop over for a podcast, huh? Well, I mean, somebody's got to pay the doctor bills. You understand? We don't have healthcare in this country.
太疯狂了。我看起来很累吗？你看起来确实累。所以，坚持住，陪着你的爱人。所以你只是想顺便过来录个播客，是吗？嗯，我是说，总得有人付医药费吧。你明白吗？我们这个国家没有全民医保。
I'm like, I'm just, are they both still in the hospital? Are they both? Yeah. Yeah. Wow. And where are you? You're at home. You're at home.
我心想，他们俩还在医院吗？他们俩都在吗？是的。是的。哇。那你呢？你在家。你在家。
Doing a podcast. That's great. So you got a pretty stiff deductible, I guess. And I had to come home and sauna and cold plunge first. I mean, listen, this, this chassis, as you would say Jason, it's no fluke. Okay. Wow. That's great.
在录播客。那太棒了。所以我猜你的免赔额很高。我得先回家蒸个桑拿，泡个冷水澡。听着，这副“底盘”，正如你所说的杰森，这可不是侥幸。好吧。哇。那太棒了。
No, I actually, as you guys know, I was a little late getting here. And all of a sudden I stood up and I was like, babe, I'll be right back. Oh my God. I raced down and jumped in the car, drove home, got on here doing this and I'm, and I'm going to be right back at it. But I just actually came from feeding him myself. He took a little extra in the bottle and it was just unbelievable. Wow.
不，其实，正如你们所知，我来晚了一点。突然间我站起来说，宝贝，我马上回来。天哪。我冲下楼跳进车里，开车回家，赶到这里做这个，我马上又要回去了。但我其实刚亲自喂了他。他多喝了一点奶瓶里的奶，真是太不可思议了。哇。
That's so cool. Yeah. I'm talking about Jason. Yeah. No, I got it. I got to look at him. He looks like he's about to poop any second. I think, I think maybe I should probably have like a lift, some sort of like a, isn't
太酷了。是的。我说的是杰森。不，我明白了。我得看看他。他看起来随时都要拉屎。我想，我想也许我应该做个提拉，某种……难道
there a thing where you can kind of like cinch up your forehead a little bit and lift your, lift your, your brow back. Interested when Ed Begley had the eyes because he had alpica and then I turned his eyebrows on upside down. And I go, God, you look surprised and he says, Oh, do I, sorry, I must have put my eyebrows too high. No, no. He said, I think I put my eyebrows on upside down.
没有那种可以把前额稍微拉紧一点，把眉毛提起来的东西吗？当埃德·贝格利做完眼睛手术后，因为他有眼睑下垂，我把他的眉毛弄反了。我说，天哪，你看起来很惊讶，他说，哦，是吗？抱歉，我一定把眉毛贴得太高了。不，不。他说，我想我把眉毛贴反了。
Guys, I'm super excited about our guest today. He's a, he's a fellow that we know. We all know and we love very much. He's originally from the suburbs of Detroit. And this I didn't know graduated magna cum laude from UCLA and anthropology. What? I did not know that. And I've known this man for a long time.
伙计们，我对今天的嘉宾超级兴奋。他是一个我们认识的人。我们都认识他，也非常爱他。他来自底特律郊区。这一点我不知道，他以优异成绩毕业于加州大学洛杉矶分校，主修人类学。什么？我不知道这一点。而且我认识这个人很久了。
He's been very successful in everything he does and director movies, movies, TV shows to his marriage, to being a father, to his own podcast from which we could all learn a thing or two. Dax Shepard. Yes. I love this man. He's one of my besties. He's one of the kindest.
他在他所做的每一件事上都非常成功，从导演电影、电视剧，到他的婚姻，到为人父，再到他自己的播客，我们都能从中学习一二。戴克斯·夏普德。是的。我爱这个人。他是我最好的朋友之一。他是最善良的人之一。
Dax Shepard. I got it. Today on SmartList, we have with us the amazing Dax Shepard, everybody. Magna cum. Hang on a second. When you said magna cum laude, I knew that because I'm not jealous of the fact that he's got it. It feels me with so much joy because one of the things about Dax is you look at this son
戴克斯·夏普德。我明白了。今天在《SmartLess》，我们请来了了不起的戴克斯·夏普德，大家好。优异成绩。等一下。当你提到优异成绩时，我知道这一点，因为我并不嫉妒他拥有这个。这让我充满了喜悦，因为戴克斯的特点之一就是你看着这个家伙
of a gun. He's got an attitude. He's got the cutoff shirts that I love. He's got the guns. He's got the whole thing. And then this motherfucker is sneaky smart. Like you wouldn't believe. Wait a second, Dax, how come you didn't let us know, me know, ever that you graduated
他很有个性。他有我喜欢的露肩衬衫。他有肌肉。他有这一切。然后这个混蛋聪明得离谱。简直让你不敢相信。等一下，戴克斯，你怎么从来没让我们，没让我知道你毕业时
magna cum? That seems like something you might lead with. From UCLA. Yeah, from UCLA. Under promise over deliver boys. Wait, wait, wait. I have to write that down. Get the guard down, get the guard down, Chauncey gardener it, and then sweep in and get all
成绩优异？这听起来像是你应该先说出来的事。来自加州大学洛杉矶分校。是的，来自加州大学洛杉矶分校。降低预期，超额交付，伙计们。等等，等等。我得把它记下来。放下戒备，像钱斯·加德纳那样，然后横扫一切，赢得
your women. I'm kind of dead serious. I'm really shocked. Barney, your lady, although I've not met her and she's just with child, she's mine. Geez, I knew that. It's cutthroat. Is the kid yours too? I don't want another kid for crying out loud.
你的女人们。我是认真的。我真的很震惊。巴尼，你的女士，虽然我没见过她，而且她正怀着孩子，她是我的。天哪，我知道。这太残酷了。孩子也是你的吗？我可不想再要个孩子了，看在上帝的份上。
No, I just want another bedmate. If he wanted it, he'd take it. Wait, are you dipping right now? Hang on a second. Are you dipping? You're dipping. Yeah, you're chewing. Dax is chewing.
不，我只是想要个床伴。如果他想要，他就会拿走。等等，你现在在嚼烟草吗？等一下。你在嚼烟草吗？你在嚼。是的。你在嚼。戴克斯在嚼烟草。
Wait, do you have chewing tobacco in your mouth right now? Let's just put me right on blast four eyes. Yeah. No. Oh, sorry. We don't want to go down this road. You want to start picking fights, lighting fires? Yeah, magna cum laude and dipping.
等等，你嘴里现在有嚼烟吗？别把我直接曝光给四眼看。是的。不。哦，抱歉。我们不想走这条路。你想挑起争端，点燃战火吗？是的，成绩优异却在嚼烟。
Jason, here's where you could learn from Dax. When I did Dax's podcast, he let me up there in his space. He let me blow some darts and I was killing the butts and he never mentioned it on the air and then he comes on here. He's not on here six seconds before you're blowing up his spot. Wait, is that a secret? Are you supposed to keep that quiet, chewing tobacco? I know.
杰森，这就是你可以向戴克斯学习的地方。当我上戴克斯的播客时，他让我进入了他的空间。他让我抽了几口，我当时正处于巅峰状态，他却在节目里只字未提，然后他来到这里。他还没待够六秒，你就把他的底细给揭了。等等，那是秘密吗？嚼烟草这种事应该保密吗？我知道。
I never knew that. I never knew that about you. Magna cum laude quite nicely. Exactly. And in the rare event that there's like 10 or 15 young men who look up to me, I find it hard to believe, but I certainly wouldn't want them packing a dip just to be like me. I'm not trying to promote that. Now, look, yeah, do I have some bad habits still?
我从来不知道。我从来不知道你这一点。成绩优异，挺好的。没错。而且万一有10到15个年轻人仰慕我，虽然我觉得很难相信，但我肯定不想让他们为了像我一样而嚼烟。我不是想推广这个。现在，看，是的，我还有一些坏习惯吗？
Yeah, I've cleaned up a bunch of them, but there's some left in this chewing tobacco. Look, I'm on and off it, on and off it, and in quarantine. I'm all the fucking way on it. It's not the loose stuff though. Your band, that's right. No, no, I got a big, let me, let me, look at that thing. Have you ever swallowed it by mistake? Probably while drunk, drinking, yeah, yeah, you know, out of a, out of an old beer bottle
是的，我已经改掉了很多，但还剩下一些，比如这个嚼烟。看，我断断续续地嚼，在隔离期间。我完全沉迷其中。不过不是散装的那种。你的带子，没错。不，不，我有一个大的，让我，让我，看看那个东西。你有没有不小心吞下去过？可能在喝醉的时候，是的，是的，你知道，从一个
that I've been spitting in. It happened. My brothers used to chew and would swallow and then throw it up to manage their weight or no, because they were probably drunk. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's what I loved about being a drunk and I think a few of you can relate is that you'd
我一直在往里吐的旧啤酒瓶里。发生过。我兄弟以前嚼烟，会吞下去，然后吐出来以控制体重，或者不，因为他们可能喝醉了。是的。是的。是的。这就是我喜欢当酒鬼的原因，我想你们中有些人能感同身受，那就是你
show up on vacation, you don't need a game plan, just have a couple of cocktails at the bar and everything else presents itself. You meet someone next to you that you would never hang out with, but you're lit. He's got to come to my bungalow, great. He's got these pills. Yeah. Now we heard of a dance club. You know, everything just happens.
度假时出现，不需要计划，只要在酒吧喝几杯鸡尾酒，一切自然就会发生。你会遇到旁边一个你平时绝不会交往的人，但你喝高了。他得来我的平房，太棒了。他有这些药片。是的。现在我们听说了一个舞厅。你知道，一切就这样发生了。
All you got to do is just get that first drink down and everything takes care of itself. And in sobriety, when I went on vacation, I'm like, what, what, go by the pool and watch other people pound cocktails responsibly. Right. Right. Wait. So, but what age were you when you started doing all that? A partying.
你所要做的就是喝下第一杯酒，剩下的事自然会解决。而在清醒状态下，当我度假时，我心想，什么，去泳池边看别人负责任地狂饮鸡尾酒。对。对。等等。所以，你开始做这一切时多大？聚会。
Yeah. Yeah. Well, I had a year in high school where I actually spoke to my mother and I said, look, I know dad's an alcoholic and everyone in the family's an alcoholic, but I'm going to need to find out for myself. And she said, I really wish you wouldn't do this, but I'm going to allow it. But with the understanding that if it gets out of control, you promise me you'll listen to me.
是的。是的。嗯，我在高中有一年，我实际上和我母亲谈过，我说，看，我知道爸爸是个酒鬼，家里每个人都是酒鬼，但我需要自己去发现。她说，我真的希望你不要这样做，但我会允许你。但前提是如果失控了，你答应我会听我的。
And I said, yeah, I can commit to that. And then I was woken up on one Saturday morning because the local law was at the house on a Saturday morning and they wanted to speak to her son. And that proved to be the nail in it. So I then shut it down for my full senior year because I respected her and then I went back at it when I graduated and then I did 11 hard years. Wow. Good for you.
我说，是的，我可以承诺。然后在一个周六早上我被叫醒了，因为当地警察周六早上在家里，他们想和她的儿子谈谈。事实证明那是最后一根稻草。所以我整个高三都戒了，因为我尊重她，然后我毕业后又开始了，然后我度过了艰难的11年。哇。为你高兴。
Good for you for getting back at it too. Because a lot of guys would have given it up and just thrown in the towel, but this guy's got to get up and get it. He's got an engine on him that don't quit. Yeah. Yeah. I said, look, I think this law enforcement showing up at my house in the morning, that's got to be an anomaly.
为你重新开始也感到高兴。因为很多人会放弃，直接认输，但这家伙必须站起来去争取。他有一股永不言弃的劲头。是的。是的。我说，看，我认为警察早上出现在我家，那一定是个反常现象。
That can't happen again. Now, Dex, I truly do want to know, I've always wanted to ask you, because when you said you started this podcast, I don't know, two years ago, three years ago, I don't know how long it was. Two and a half. And you were like, I'm doing this podcast. I'm on my attic. I'm like, what?
那不可能再发生了。现在，戴克斯，我真的想知道，我一直想问你，因为当你两年前，三年前，我不知道多久以前，说你开始做这个播客时。两年半。你说你要做这个播客。我在我的阁楼里。我心想，什么？
I didn't understand. What made you want to do it? I was a pretty regular guest on some of them. And the feedback I got, say from Mark Marin, where dozens of dudes had stopped me over the years and said, like, hey, man, I listened to that episode pretty often. I got sober after hearing it. I always kind of go back to it. I had had so many guys tell me that.
我不明白。是什么让你想做这个？我曾是其中一些播客的常客。我得到的反馈，比如马克·马龙的节目，多年来有几十个家伙拦住我说，嘿，伙计，我经常听那一集。听完之后我戒酒了。我总是会回过头去听。有很多人这样告诉我。
And I was like, I don't feel that when I'm in a movie looking in the barrel over Don Johnson's shoulder. No one stops me and says that got me sober, although certainly someone got sober because of that. But I was just, I was really, really moved with the, the response of being a guest on like Sam Jones, Mark Marin, a few of the long form ones. And as all of us have done, we're all comedians and we've all done a million talk shows. You know, that pressure to be amazing in six minutes, which is fun.
我心想，当我在电影里看着唐·约翰逊的肩膀时，我没有那种感觉。没人拦住我说那让我戒酒了，虽然肯定有人因为那个戒酒了。但我真的，真的被作为嘉宾参加像萨姆·琼斯、马克·马龙等一些长篇访谈节目的反响所感动。正如我们所有人都做过的那样，我们都是喜剧演员，我们都做过一百万个脱口秀。你知道，那种在六分钟内表现出色的压力，这很有趣。
I love it. I love being on talk shows. But I wanted for like, oh, I have more thoughts and I have more to offer and I have a bigger story to tell and I want to do it. But just again, largely just enjoying being on the long form one so much and generally being open to being on people's and just always loving the experience. I was like, I want to do this all the time. But do you miss, like, I've worked with each one of you individually for months at a time
我喜欢它。我喜欢上脱口秀。但我想要，哦，我有更多的想法，我有更多的东西可以提供，我有更大的故事要讲，我想做。但再次强调，主要是因为我非常喜欢参加长篇访谈，而且通常乐于参加别人的节目，总是喜欢这种体验。我心想，我想一直这样做。但你怀念吗，比如，我和你们每个人都单独工作过好几个月
on multiple projects. And one of the things I love and one, it's probably one of the reasons I do this is because I love that experience, not just doing the scene, but I love hanging out with, with guys like you and people like you and gals like you, like having fun and laughing. I've had some of my greatest experiences working, have been with all three of you guys where I've had a great time. Likewise. Oh, that's everything.
在多个项目上。我喜欢的一点，可能也是我做这个的原因之一，是因为我喜欢那种体验，不仅仅是演戏，我喜欢和你们这样的人，和像你们这样的人，和像你们这样的女孩一起玩，一起开心，一起大笑。我在工作中经历过一些最棒的时刻，都是和你们三个人在一起，我玩得很开心。同样。哦，那是一切。
That's the whole reason to do the job after a while. It's such a blast and so, and formed really great lifelong relationships with all three of you guys. So does that, do you miss that part of it? Do you feel like a lone or no? Well, I just shot, you know, 28 episodes of Bless Us Mass and I'm also on Top Gear and I also host the game show. So I'm doing more than enough of that.
那才是工作一段时间后做这份工作的全部理由。这太棒了，而且真的和你们三个人建立了很棒的终身关系。所以，你怀念那部分吗？你觉得孤独吗，还是不？嗯，我刚拍了28集《Bless Us Mass》，我也在《Top Gear》里，我还主持游戏节目。所以我做的已经足够多了。
Of course. Yeah. In fact, it's, yeah, more and more with it, when you just look at the amount of energy required and time committed and two kids and all that, less and less do I want to be on a like scripted show that takes 65 hours a week, nine months of the year. It's just, yeah, it's less and less appealing to me. You know, all my, all my acting aspirations are, are gone in a healthy way. What about your directing stuff though, because you're a great director and you're able to,
当然。是的。事实上，是的，随着你看看所需的能量和投入的时间，还有两个孩子等等，我越来越不想参加那种一年九个月、每周65小时的剧本剧了。这对我来说越来越没有吸引力了。你知道，我所有的表演抱负，都以一种健康的方式消失了。那你导演的东西呢，因为你是个伟大的导演，你能够
you know, juggle a bunch of balls at the same time and guide multiple departments and, and shape and experience for an audience. Is that something that you think you'll, you'll return to? I mean, I recognize it's a bit of a time suck and you're super busy, you know, on the top of the hill. But, you know, do you see that sometime in the future? Um, because you did, you used to saying that how much you loved it. I love it.
你知道，同时抛接多个球，指导多个部门，并为观众塑造一种体验。那是你认为你会回归的事情吗？我是说，我知道这有点耗时，而且你超级忙，你知道，在山顶上。但是，你知道，你觉得未来某个时候会吗？嗯，因为你曾经说过你有多喜欢它。我喜欢它。
There is nothing more fun than when you're in production directing. To me, it's the closest thing you can get to doing cocaine, uh, with kind of no downside. You're just, when you're there as an actor, as you guys know, you're, you're like, when are we getting out of here? That's, I arrive and I ask when we're, when are we getting out of here as a director? The thing flips entirely where it's like, how long can we stay? I want to shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot now. And maybe we could add this thing and like just that flip of, of wanting to be there
没有什么比在制作中导演更有趣的了。对我来说，这是你能得到的最接近吸食可卡因的东西，而且几乎没有负面影响。你只是，当你作为演员在那里时，正如你们所知，你会想，我们什么时候能离开这里？那是，我到达时就会问我们什么时候能离开这里，作为导演，情况完全反转了，就像，我们能待多久？我想拍，拍，拍，拍，现在就拍。也许我们可以加上这个东西，就像那种想要待在那里
and wanting more time and, and, and the control, the control of, of, of solving problems as they arise. Cause there's no, there's no game plan for a movie unless you have 130 days like Tarantino and you can sit around and wait for the sun to be where you thought it was going to be X, Y and Z. You know, Bateman, you do it all the time. You map something out, you got there, you guys got there three hours later, the sun's now in a different spot. You're now shooting on that side of the street instead of this side of the street.
想要更多时间，以及控制，解决问题时的控制感。因为电影没有游戏计划，除非你有像昆汀那样的130天，你可以坐着等太阳到你预想的位置。你知道，贝特曼，你经常这样做。你规划好一切，你到了那里，你们晚了三个小时，太阳现在在不同的位置。你现在在街的那一边拍摄，而不是这一边。
And I love solving problems. So I love going, okay, well, how can we make this work on the other side of the street? That's very stimulating for me. So I love it. Do I love editing for four months and then testing over and over again? I fucking hate that. Do I love promoting and getting tracking for fucking two months, knowing you're just going and promoting for no reason and it's going to tank, you know, all that stuff that the
我喜欢解决问题。所以我喜欢说，好吧，我们怎么才能让它在街的那一边工作？这对我很刺激。所以我喜欢它。我喜欢剪辑四个月然后一遍又一遍地测试吗？我他妈讨厌那个。我喜欢推广和追踪两个月吗，明知道你只是在推广，毫无意义，而且它会失败，你知道，所有那些
risk reward is just unappealing to me currently. That part of it's dead though. I'll bet you that. It is. You're so right. So what I want to like write a pilot and shoot the pilot, yeah, I think I would like to do that. That seems like something that would be manageable.
风险回报目前对我来说毫无吸引力。那部分已经死了。我敢打赌。确实。你说得太对了。所以我想要写个试播集并拍摄它，是的，我想我会喜欢那样做。那看起来像是可以管理的事情。
And then you're not so dependent on the studio to promote it and all these other things. But yeah, just the heartbreak of like two years and then you and then your whole life's decided on a Friday. I just don't need that again. It would be like for me, you know, having a boyfriend that kicked my ass and going back to that. Why would I do that to myself? Tell me about it.
然后你就不那么依赖制片厂去推广它和所有其他事情了。但是，是的，那种两年的心碎，然后你的整个人生在周五被决定。我真的不需要再经历一次了。那对我来说就像，有一个打我的男朋友，然后又回到他身边。我为什么要对自己做这种事？别提了。
Two and a half months of shooting isn't worth that to me. I last year as a mantra, as a mantra, I would be saying, your opinion's not needed here. Like just as a everywhere I go, your opinion is not needed here because I think everyone must hear my opinion on all fucking topics and it's just these people are doing just fine when I'm not around. Right, how do they make it without you? Yeah, I think Chris and I have both said that to each other in fights. Do you think that I just arrived here like by accident, like I was doing plenty good
两个半月的拍摄对我来说不值得那样。去年作为一个口头禅，作为一个口头禅，我会说，这里不需要你的意见。就像我去的任何地方，这里不需要你的意见，因为我觉得每个人都必须听到我对所有他妈的话题的意见，而这些人即使我不在身边也做得很好。对，没有你他们怎么活？是的，我想克里斯和我在争吵中都对彼此说过。你觉得我是偶然来到这里的吗，就像我做得很好
without you. I was eating and taking dumps and showering. Everything was, the bills were paid. Right. Yeah. Now, Dex, I know you jumped around because last time we talked a week ago or two weeks ago. You said you had mentioned about jumping around from house to house when you were a kid from
没有你。我在吃饭，拉屎，洗澡。一切都很好，账单都付清了。对。是的。现在，戴克斯，我知道你跳来跳去，因为上次我们谈话是在一周前或两周前。你说过你小时候从一个房子搬到另一个房子，从
stepfather to stepfather and it was very uneasy and kind of like, you know, I had a hard childhood too as you know, but talk about that a little bit and like why that was unstable for you and what did that drive you to do or not to in your adult life? Like how do you, and by the way, was comedy an escape from all of that as well? Did you like, I got to get out of here. The only way to deal with this is drugs, alcohol and laughing. Sorry. Dex, B1, this is a 14-pronged question.
继父搬到继父，这非常不安，而且有点像，你知道，我也度过了一个艰难的童年，正如你所知，但谈谈那个，为什么这对你来说不稳定，这驱使你在成年生活中去做或不做些什么？就像你如何，顺便问一下，喜剧也是逃避这一切的一种方式吗？你是否觉得，我得离开这里。处理这个的唯一方法就是毒品、酒精和大笑。抱歉。戴克斯，B1，这是一个14个分支的问题。
Go ahead. Well, I'll just say I'm going to parse this out. I think I heard why are you a comedian and why are you an alcoholic, so let me try to sum that up. Oh, so I'm coming through loud and clear then. Yeah. Yeah. And you guys are, you guys are five-hour episodes.
继续。嗯，我只想说我会解析一下。我想我听到了为什么你是喜剧演员，为什么你是酒鬼，所以让我试着总结一下。哦，所以我说得很清楚了。是的。是的。你们是五小时的剧集。
There's going to be a two-parter. Special two-parter. Yeah, because I just, I want to plot out my answer. I want to come, I want to land the plane in under three. Can I just say before you start, can I just say before, before you start your answer, can I just say, because I don't think it came out enough, how goddamn happy I am that Dex is here. Yeah, it's pretty bitchy.
会有两部分。特别的两部分。是的，因为我只是，我想规划我的答案。我想在三小时内着陆。在我开始之前，我能说一句话吗，在我开始之前，我能说一句话吗，因为我觉得表达得还不够，戴克斯在这里我有多他妈高兴。是的，这太刻薄了。
This is such a fucking joy. Yeah. I've just, I don't know if you heard Dex had a kid. My son was born yesterday at a newborn, and I'm sitting here with three of my fucking old-timey pals, and this feels so goddamn good, and I'm so happy it's you. Go ahead. I love it. God, listen to all the love oozing out of this softy new dad.
这真是他妈的快乐。是的。我只是，我不知道你是否听说戴克斯有了个孩子。我的儿子昨天出生，是个新生儿，我正坐在这里，和三个我他妈的老朋友在一起，这感觉太他妈好了，我很高兴是你。继续。我喜欢它。天哪，听听这个软弱的新爸爸流露出的所有爱。
I love it. I love it. I wish I could face you right on the mouth. How masculine is Arnett? He just can't have a girl. No, I know. Like you and I can only have girls. Exactly.
我喜欢它。我喜欢它。我真希望我能直接面对面。阿奈特有多阳刚？他就是生不出男孩。不，我知道。就像你和我只能生女孩。没错。
And this guy's on propitia and still making boys. Nothing but testosterone coming out of him. That was my explanation for having all girls. I'm like, it must be the propitia. I'm on Dettrol Hydroxy Testosterone. I am on nothing but propitia. That's all I need. If you kept going, you'd have a fucking football team on your hands in no time, Arnett.
而这家伙在吃保法止，还能生男孩。他身上散发出的全是睾酮。这就是我生全是女孩的解释。我心想，一定是保法止。我正在服用Dettrol羟基睾酮。我只服用保法止。这就是我所需要的。如果你继续下去，你很快就会拥有一支他妈的足球队，阿奈特。
It's crazy. Anyways. Like an entire police force. Look, I have a genetic predisposition. I come by it honestly. A lot of shepherds were alcoholics. I got some uncles that shot each other, a lot of my people in prison. We're all from Northern Kentucky that migrated to Michigan.
太疯狂了。总之。就像一支完整的警察部队。看，我有遗传倾向。我来得光明正大。很多谢泼德家的人都是酒鬼。我有几个叔叔互相射击，我很多亲戚在监狱里。我们都来自北肯塔基州，后来搬到了密歇根州。
So that's the gun. And then what loaded it is, you pointed out, was lots of stepped dads, some physical violence, some sexual abuse. And then a penchant for fucking fun, love and life. So just a thrilling, but I would say probably the biggest catalyst was, with the absence of a father figure giving me approval, I sought it with reckless abandon from my peers. And my peers were all about how hard could you party? How could you fight?
所以那是枪。然后装填它的是，正如你指出的，大量的继父，一些身体暴力，一些性虐待。还有对该死的乐趣、爱和生活的热爱。所以只是一个惊险的，但我会说可能最大的催化剂是，在没有父亲形象给我认可的情况下，我从同龄人那里疯狂地寻求它。而我的同龄人都在谈论你能玩得多疯？你能打架吗？
How far could you jump a motorcycle? How long could you wheelie? And I was like, sign me up for all these. I want the masculine credentials. I want to be a man. And I did all those things. And it should be noted that you probably did those things more than all those people who challenged you to knowing Dax.
你能骑摩托车跳多远？你能翘头多久？我心想，帮我报名参加所有这些。我想要阳刚的资历。我想成为一个男人。我做了所有这些事情。而且应该指出的是，你可能比所有那些挑战你的人做得更多，了解戴克斯。
Well, all those things happened at the same time on some occasions, show up lit on a motorcycle to the bar and start swinging. So you can dovetail them all into one explosion. And then yeah, unlike you gentlemen, I was auditioning for 10 years in LA and could not get a job, couldn't book a commercial. And that was, that was rough. And yeah, booze was a nice little vacation from that. Hard to see everybody around you, kind of, especially you were at the groundlings, which
嗯，所有这些事情在某些场合同时发生，骑着摩托车醉醺醺地来到酒吧，然后开始挥拳。所以你可以把它们全部拼凑成一次爆炸。然后是的，不像你们这些绅士，我在洛杉矶试镜了10年，找不到工作，接不到广告。那，那很艰难。而且是的，酒是逃避那个的一个不错的假期。很难看到周围的每个人，特别是你在Groundlings，这
is kind of like Second City and all of the other improv classes. Hard to be around all those other people who are like booking stuff left and right. And you were in the groundlings with Melissa McCarthy and just all these huge names. Yeah. And I'd go home and I'd pop on the TV to watch basketball and all of my classmates and peers were selling auto insurance and fast food and, you know, and they were all just quietly making like, you know, 70 grand a year doing commercials. And I instead was driving cross country for General Motors to make ends meet.
有点像第二城和其他所有的即兴表演班。很难和所有那些像疯了一样预订工作的人在一起。而你在Groundlings和梅丽莎·麦卡锡以及所有这些大牌在一起。是的。我会回家打开电视看篮球，我所有的同学和同龄人都在卖汽车保险和快餐，你知道，他们都在悄悄地赚着，你知道，一年7万块钱拍广告。而我却在为通用汽车开车横跨全国以维持生计。
Which I'm sure they were jealous of. They were so jealous. They were like, how many hours are you in that car on the weekend? I'm like, around 72. I think I even blew by Bateman and his buddy on their infamous ski trip in that van. Now, all right. Now listen. Wait a second.
我相信他们很嫉妒。他们太嫉妒了。他们问，你周末在车里待了多少小时？我说，大约72小时。我想我甚至在他们那次臭名昭著的滑雪旅行中超过了贝特曼和他的伙伴。现在，好了。现在听着。等等。
Wait a second. What is this story, Garrett? It was a 40 foot boundary, not a van. How dare you? Was it beef, Garrett? Oh God. Have I ever told you this story? Give people context.
等等。这是什么故事，加勒特？那是一个40英尺的边界，不是面包车。你怎么敢？是牛肉吗，加勒特？哦，上帝。我给你讲过这个故事吗？给人们背景。
Come on. Yeah. Give us context, Bates. I tried to get it all out of them on my podcast, but it was too dangerous. So maybe on his, he'll feel empowered to tell us the truth. You got to. You have to now. In his retelling on my podcast, there's just some gaps in time that he has no explanation
来吧。是的。给我们背景，贝茨。我试着在我的播客里从他们那里挖出来，但太危险了。所以也许在他的节目里，他会感到有权告诉我们真相。你必须。你现在必须。在他对我的播客的重述中，有一些时间间隔他无法解释
for. But we all know what the fuck. I think we went down a rabbit hole about a wiping techniques. I think that that's exhausted our time. I heard that. So Leif and I, Leif and I were buddies because he, Leif Garrett, yeah, he was dating my sister and, and I, I just thought he was just the coolest thing in the world. And then they broke up and he and I stayed friends and I was thrilled about it.
。但我们都知道他妈的。我想我们钻进了一个关于擦拭技术的兔子洞。我想那已经耗尽了我们的时间。我听说了。所以利夫和我，利夫和我曾是哥们，因为他，利夫·加勒特，是的，他在和我姐姐约会，我，我只是觉得他是世界上最酷的人。然后他们分手了，他和我也保持了朋友关系，我对此感到非常激动。
And he was a great skier and knew his way around a bottle of booze and he admired his skiing prowess and everything else. No, this, this guy, this guy's it. And then I pitched, I wanted to just take him away. You know, I wanted him all to myself. So I said, Hey, how about, how about we go on a ski trip, Angel? And he said, he said, great. So we rented a, a motor home, stocked it up with all you can handle and read between
他是个很棒的滑雪者，知道怎么对付一瓶酒，我钦佩他的滑雪技术和其他一切。不，这个，这个家伙，这个家伙太棒了。然后我提议，我只是想把他带走。你知道，我想把他据为己有。所以我说，嘿，我们去滑雪旅行怎么样，天使？他说，他说，太棒了。所以我们租了一辆房车，装满了你可以处理的所有东西，在字里行间阅读
the lines. Yeah. We put two, two mountain bikes on the roof so we could, we could travel from the, from the, from the RV parking lots into, into the main town, wherever we'd, we'd go. And we, we plotted a loop. We went north from Los Angeles to mammoth. Then we went to Tahoe. Then we went to Jackson Hole.
。是的。我们在车顶放了两辆山地自行车，这样我们就可以，我们就可以从，从，从房车停车场进入，进入主城镇，无论我们去哪里。我们，我们策划了一个环线。我们从洛杉矶向北去猛犸象。然后我们去了太浩湖。然后我们去了杰克逊霍尔。
We went to Sun Valley. We went to Aspen. We went to. You went to a lot of places. Yeah. Utah. Yeah. Yeah.
我们去了太阳谷。我们去了阿斯彭。我们去了。你们去了很多地方。是的。犹他州。是的。是的。
We don't need the itinerary. Well, but. You put some miles on it. But that's significant, right? Where'd you gas up in between? I mean. Oh, so we took a couple of weeks. I would say the beauty of the story is in the details statement.
我们不需要行程。嗯，但是。你跑了不少里程。但那很重要，对吧？你在中间在哪里加油？我是说。哦，所以我们花了几周时间。我会说故事的美妙之处在于细节，贝特曼。
Okay. Sorry. Don't spare us any. Yeah. I love every one of these stops. I can't do them any more details than just destinations, mostly because I can't remember. Once we, once we turn the, the rig off, things got a little cloudy. It should be noted as hardcore that is, and you guys going on this trip or you're filling
好的。抱歉。别省掉任何细节。是的。我喜欢每一个站点。我不能给他们任何细节，除了目的地，主要是因为我不记得了。一旦我们，一旦我们关掉房车，事情就变得有点模糊了。应该指出的是，这很硬核，你们去这次旅行或者你们在填
the RV full of parties, supplies and stuff. The nerd element is, and we had the mountain bike so we could go from wherever just into the town. Like what? Nerd. And that's a new development for me. Can I tell you what I thought when you originally told me there were mountain bikes involved and, and skis, I was like, God bless these guys.
房车里装满了派对，补给品之类的东西。书呆子元素是，我们有山地自行车，这样我们就可以从任何地方进入城镇。像什么？书呆子。那是我的新发展。我能告诉你我最初听到有山地自行车和滑雪板时在想什么吗，我心想，上帝保佑这些家伙。
They're doing some downhill mountain biking. Like I assume when they come out of elevation and it gets warmer, they're in Moab maybe on the mountain bikes. No, no, no. It's drunk. No, no. It's a, it's a winter trip. So we're riding these mountain bikes in the snow, pretty lit up.
他们在做一些下坡山地自行车运动。就像我假设当他们走出海拔变暖时，他们可能在摩押骑山地自行车。不，不，不。是醉酒。不，不。这是一个冬季旅行。所以我们在雪地里骑这些山地自行车，喝得烂醉。
So it, it was tough. Do you remember my first follow-up question when you told me that story privately? I do not. I said, if and how often were you and Leif both making love in the same RV at the same time? It's close quarters. I bet I had a pretty colorful answer for that. Listen, this is, this is great and I love, thank you Dax for saying make love.
所以它，它很艰难。你还记得我私下告诉你那个故事时的第一个后续问题吗？我不记得了。我说，你和利夫在同一辆房车里做爱，频率是多少？空间很小。我敢打赌我有一个相当丰富多彩的答案。听着，这，这很棒，我喜欢，谢谢戴克斯说做爱。
Good for you. Yeah. Yeah. This is a couple of thrill seekers, romantics. They're on the road for God knows how long. Not a fuck trip. This was, this was beautiful mountains and making love and rivers and, and light snow. Good for you.
为你高兴。是的。是的。这是一对寻求刺激的人，浪漫主义者。他们在路上待了天知道多久。不是他妈的旅行。这是，这是美丽的群山和做爱，还有河流，和轻雪。为你高兴。
Because I want to, I want to get back to like life stuff because I love it and I don't, I wasn't there at this, in the story, so I'm kind of bored by it. Oh my God. Okay. Sean, I'll, I'll spice it up for you. Any dudes come in that fucking RV. Finally. Finally.
因为我想，我想回到生活琐事上，因为我喜欢它，而且我当时不在这个故事里，所以我有点厌烦它。天哪。好的。肖恩，我，我会为你加点料。有任何家伙进那辆他妈的房车吗。终于。终于。
Jesus. God. All of a sudden. Swing their wangs around at all. My earphones just popped up a little bit. Trust me. You guys are seeing, you guys know when you work with Sean, it's like, yeah, your line, your line, your line, my line.
耶稣。上帝。突然间。甩动他们的阴茎。我的耳机稍微弹出来了一点。相信我。你们看到的，你们知道当你们和肖恩一起工作时，就像，是的，你的台词，你的台词，你的台词，我的台词。
Right. Your line, your line. Everybody else talks. Everybody else talks. Thank you for teaching me that, Will. So obviously the four of us have been friends for a super long time and know, know everything about each other or almost everything about each other. I didn't know about the Magnum Cool Outer, but, but for the people listening who don't
对。你的台词，你的台词。其他人说话。其他人说话。谢谢你教我那个，威尔。所以显然我们四个人已经做了很久的朋友，知道，知道关于彼此的一切，或者几乎关于彼此的一切。我不知道关于优异成绩的事，但是，对于听众来说，他们不知道
know, like you're one of the funniest people I've ever known, Dax. And like when you were going from house to house, stepfather to stepfather, like for me, I didn't, I didn't fall into the trap of drugs and alcohol, like the three of you did. Not yet. So it's not a competition. So not yet. And so my true escape, my nerd escape was Saturday Night Live and comedy because it made me, if I could laugh or make other people laugh, it made me feel euphoric.
，就像你是认识的最有趣的人之一，戴克斯。而且就像你从一个房子搬到另一个房子，从继父搬到继父时，就像我，我没有，我没有陷入毒品和酒精的陷阱，像你们三个那样。还没。所以这不是比赛。所以还没。所以我的真正逃避，我的书呆子逃避是《周六夜现场》和喜剧，因为它让我，如果我能笑或者让别人笑，它让我感到欣快。
That was my corny, dumb, nerdy drug because I didn't do drugs, right? So for you running around, doing all that, what were, who were your influences and who were, who did you watch and was comedy as much of an escape as a drug like it was for me? Okay. So what I love about this is I'm juggling three balls and I'm juggling Sean Hayes and Bateman and Arnett and it's great. So I'm going to click in, you're in the air right now, you're in the air.
那是我的俗气、愚蠢、书呆子毒品，因为我不吸毒，对吧？所以对于你跑来跑去，做所有这些，什么是，谁是你的影响者，谁是，你看了谁，喜剧像对我一样是逃避毒品的一种方式吗？好的。所以我喜欢的是我正在抛接三个球，我正在抛接肖恩·海耶斯、贝特曼和阿奈特，这太棒了。所以我准备切入，你现在在空中，你在空中。
But to answer your question. So what I like about is I'm clicking back from sincere to, to getting roasted. But to, to that I would say the other element was I was, you know, severely dyslexic and I went to the learning disabled room for an hour a day and they knocked on the door and they basically brought me and the other guy out. You can imagine what he looked like. It was demoralizing and yeah, my defense for that was I was, I was funny. But I think it now, you know, that I'm older, I really recognize its control.
但回答你的问题。所以我喜欢的是我正在从真诚切换回，被烤。但是，对此我会说另一个因素是我，你知道，严重阅读障碍，我每天去学习障碍室待一小时，他们敲门，他们基本上把我和其他家伙带出来。你可以想象他看起来像什么。这很打击士气，是的，我对此的防御是我，我很幽默。但我认为现在，你知道，我老了，我真的认识到这是控制。
Every one of these things is control. Why I like cars and motorcycles, it's all control and why I like comedies control because I'm in an awkward, we're all awkward, we're all, we all have social anxiety and I have this thing where I could take charge of the whole interaction and I could steer it and I could do something and get a predictable outcome. And I, I loved that predictability. I think my childhood was largely unpredictable and sometimes dangerous and, and just having a sense of control of my environment and the people in it.
每一件事都是控制。为什么我喜欢汽车和摩托车，这都是控制，为什么我喜欢喜剧是控制，因为我处于一个尴尬的，我们都很尴尬，我们都很，我们都有社交焦虑，我有这个东西，我可以掌控整个互动，我可以引导它，我可以做点什么并得到一个可预测的结果。而且我，我喜欢那种可预测性。我想我的童年很大程度上是不可预测的，有时是危险的，而且，只是对我的环境和其中的人有一种控制感。
That's what appealed to me. A lot of comedians will go like, Oh, I just love the joy of making other people laugh. Not me. I like control. I like predictability. Yeah. I'm not that altruistic. Yeah.
这就是吸引我的地方。很多喜剧演员会说，哦，我只是喜欢让别人笑的快乐。我不。我喜欢控制。我喜欢可预测性。是的。我没那么利他。是的。
I get that from you. Well, then that sets up well for what you're killing right now, right? And I want to talk about that. I mean, I think it is incredible, awesome, fantastic news that you're just right up on top of the mountain with what you're doing with, with your podcast. I just like, and, and, you know, we're, we're three morons trying to see if we have any idea what the hell we're doing in this space. So I want to try to pick your brain a little bit and try to keep it entertaining about
我从你那里得到了这一点。好吧，那为你现在正在做的事情打下了很好的基础，对吧？我想谈谈那个。我是说，我认为这是不可思议的，棒极了，梦幻般的消息，你正处于你用你的播客所做的事情的山顶。我只是喜欢，而且，你知道，我们是三个白痴，试图看看我们是否知道我们在做什么。所以我想要试着挖掘一下你的大脑，试着让它保持娱乐性，关于
how we try to do this half as good as you're doing it. But just, I do want to say, I said, I've told you privately, I want to tell you publicly, I just, I'm so happy for you with how incredibly successful your, your podcast is and do you like the dynamic of, of the control of that, where you, you know who the guest is, what the questions could, should be, what the angle is going to be, and then kind of pivoting inside of that and trying to be a little bit flexible, yet still in control. I mean, is that, is that an, it's an appealing thing, I bet, yeah? For sure.
我们如何试着做得像你做得一样好的一半。但是，我确实想说，我说过，我私下告诉过你，我想公开告诉你，我只是，我为你播客的不可思议的成功感到高兴，你喜欢那种控制的动态吗，在那里你，你知道嘉宾是谁，问题可能，应该是什么，角度会是什么，然后在那里面进行调整，并试着变得灵活一点，但仍然在控制之中。我是说，那是，那是一个吸引人的东西，我敢打赌，是的？当然。
It's like, it's downright euphoric when it goes well. And you really do, not to get corny, but you, you can reach a state of flow in this. It happens to me all the time where, you know, I interviewed Yuval Harari and they're like, he's got to leave in an hour. And I was like, okay. And then all of a sudden I saw the person like signaling us, he had to go. And in my mind, I would have bet my children's life on the fact that we had been talking for 12 minutes.
当它顺利时，简直是欣快。而且你真的，不是为了变得俗气，但你，你可以在这里达到一种心流状态。这经常发生在我身上，你知道，我采访了尤瓦尔·赫拉利，他们说，他一小时后得走。我心想，好吧。然后突然间我看到那个人像是在示意我们，他得走了。而在我的脑海里，我会拿我孩子的生命打赌，我们已经谈了12分钟。
Yeah. And an hour had gone by and I was like, oh my God, that reminds me of, you know, other, other aspects of our work where that can happen, it happens to me in the editing room, right? Where it's like, you're so hyper focused on this thing. And all of a sudden you're like, oh my God, I've been editing for six hours. That's crazy. Or, you know, I think any, I get that on the motorcycle track. Anytime I'm present, I'm not worrying about what Dex needs in the future or what I don't
是的，一小时过去了，我心想，哦，天哪，这让我想起，你知道，我们工作的其他方面，那种情况会发生，它发生在我剪辑室里，对吧？就像，你对这件事如此高度专注。突然间你心想，哦，天哪，我已经剪辑了六小时。这太疯狂了。或者，你知道，我想任何，我在摩托车赛道上也会那样。任何时候我活在当下，我都不担心戴克斯未来需要什么，或者我没有
have now. As soon as I escape that prison of my brain, I'm really happy and I enjoy it. And yeah, there is this great sense of, it's not unlike acting too, where it's like if you get into a scene and it's really sloppy and things are changing and you're reacting. And then all of a sudden some magic kind of happens. And that to me, that the podcast is like, it's two hours of my favorite aspect of acting. Like, can I listen? Can I respond?
现在有什么。一旦我逃离那个大脑的监狱，我真的很快乐，我很享受它。而且是的，有一种伟大的感觉，它和演戏也没什么不同，就像如果你进入一个场景，它真的很草率，事情在变化，你在反应。然后突然间某种魔法发生了。对我来说，播客就像，这是我最喜欢的演戏方面的两小时。就像，我能听吗？我能回应吗？
Can I elevate this? And I have found it, you know, I directed three movies and the whole goal of directing a movie in theory would be that you're going to let someone in on your point of view, how you're processing this world around you. And yet you're confined by the three X structure and you're confined by the rules of Aristotle and poetics. There's all these things you're confined by. And then I realized on the podcast, like, oh, I sit down for two hours, you're in my
我能提升这个吗？我发现它，你知道，我导演了三部电影，导演电影的全部目标理论上应该是你让别人进入你的观点，你如何处理你周围的世界。然而你被三幕结构所限制，你被亚里士多德和诗学的规则所限制。所有这些东西都限制着你。然后我在播客上意识到，就像，哦，我坐下来两小时，你在我的
fucking point of view. There was ever a fast pass to my point of view. It is that podcast and it's what normally takes me two years to do and I don't even succeed when I make it. So has it made directing and acting less important then? I mean, you're getting satiated with this, yeah? Yeah. You know, what's funny is I heard Joe Rogan about five years ago say he had no desire
他妈的观点里。如果曾经有一张通往我观点的快速通行证，那就是那个播客，这通常需要我两年才能做到，而且我制作它时甚至没有成功。所以它让导演和演戏变得不那么重要了吗？我是说，你对此感到满足了，是吗？是的。你知道，有趣的是，我五年前听到乔·罗根说他没有欲望
to act. And I, as a cynical piece of shit, thought, oh, that's bullshit. He's just not getting asked to act anymore and that's his story now. And now I completely, I totally believe him and it's not that I don't have a desire to act or anything. It's just that, yeah, this is fucking incredibly fulfilling. I don't have to get hair and makeup. I drive to my guest house above my garage.
去演戏。而我，作为一个愤世嫉俗的混蛋，心想，哦，那都是扯淡。他只是没人找他演戏了，所以才编出这套说辞。但现在我完全、彻底地相信他了，并不是说我没有演戏的欲望什么的。只是，是的，这真的太有成就感了。我不需要去弄头发和化妆。我开车去我车库上面的客房。
There's so many elements that are heaven about it. One of the things that's really great, this is more sort of an observation is that, and I bet the other guys will back me up on this, is that you are a guy who's very, very interested in the world around and you're very interested in other people and what other people's perspectives are. You're often blown away when confronted with somebody else's perspective that's really cool to watch. You'd be like, wow, this motherfucker thinks this, that's crazy.
这其中有很多令人愉悦的元素。其中一件非常棒的事情，这更像是一种观察，我敢说其他人也会支持我的观点，那就是，你是一个对周围世界非常、非常感兴趣的人，你对其他人以及他人的观点非常感兴趣。当你面对别人的观点时，你经常会感到震惊，这看起来真的很酷。你会说，哇，这个混蛋竟然这么想，太疯狂了。
But not bad, more like, that's wild. That's not how I looked at it and you hear that when you talk to people. So well, one thing was, I don't know if you guys watched that Michael Jordan documentary. Yeah, it's great and it's hit me a couple to say, I watched it's not fair and injected it or something. It's so great. And do you know, do you remember the part where the guy said, Jordan wasn't the best fastest runner, the best shooter or whatever, but never has there been somebody who's been
但不是坏的那种，更像是，太狂野了。那不是我看待事物的方式，当你和人们交谈时，你会听到这些。所以，有一件事是，我不知道你们有没有看那个迈克尔·乔丹的纪录片。是的，它很棒，它让我有几次想说，我看了，这不公平，或者别的什么。它太棒了。你知道，你还记得那个人说的那部分吗，乔丹不是最快的跑者，不是最好的射手什么的，但从来没有人像他那样
more in the present moment than that guy. He's always in the present moment. And I think that that's what you're kind of touching on that desire to be. I understand that and I understand to the extent that I'd love to be able to connect with it as much as possible because when I do, it feels so fucking good. And that's what I hear coming through from you. Like that desire to be right there in that moment, like you said, when you're on the motorcycle track or doing the podcast, right, like that's the kind of zone you want to live
更活在当下。他总是活在当下。我想这就是你所触及的那种渴望。我理解这一点，我也理解到我希望能尽可能多地与它建立联系，因为当我这样做时，感觉真的太棒了。这就是我从你身上听到的。就像你说的，那种想要活在当下的渴望，比如当你在摩托车赛道上或者做播客时，对吧，那就是你想居住的区域。
in. Howard Stern does that really well. There's a sincere curiosity about other people's perspective and really stays engaged in his conversations with people. You do that incredibly well too. Yeah. And I got to tell you, so two things. One, I just want to give full credit to AA.
霍华德·斯特恩（Howard Stern）做得非常好。他对别人的观点有一种真诚的好奇心，并且真正地沉浸在他与人的对话中。你也做得非常好。是的。我得告诉你，有两件事。第一，我只想把所有的功劳都归给戒酒互助会（AA）。
The whole reason I'm any of the things you guys might compliment is from AA. 15 years ago, you would have liked me. I was a blast at the party and I would have fought for you guys, but that it would have ended there. You wouldn't have asked me to like help you do anything and expect me to show up. So I give all credit to that. And then also I just want to say as far as the podcast and as far as you guys are concerned, I asked Chris Hardwick, because I had him on early and he's obviously done tremendous
你们可能称赞我的所有事情，全部原因都在于AA。15年前，你们会喜欢我的。我在派对上是个开心果，我会为你们挺身而出，但也就仅此而已了。你们不会让我帮你们做任何事，也不会指望我能出现。所以我把所有的功劳都归功于此。然后我还想说，就播客而言，就你们而言，我问过克里斯·哈德威克（Chris Hardwick），因为我早些时候请过他，他显然在这方面做得非常出色。
in this. And I said, what advice do you have for me? And he said, you know, the less and less I prepare, the better I am. He said, because inevitably, if you're trying to lead someone to a story, best case scenario, you'll hear that story. Great. But you already knew that story. So there's limits to your engagement.
我问他，你有什么建议给我？他说，你知道，我准备得越少，我就表现得越好。他说，因为不可避免地，如果你试图引导某人讲一个故事，最好的情况是，你会听到那个故事。很好。但你已经知道那个故事了。所以你的参与度是有限的。
You can only be so interested in something that you already know the outcome of. And it's palpable. And he said, you know, be flexible, let the thing go where it goes. Don't try to steer it. You know, have some flags planted, but, but, you know, really be open to what can happen. And the more the times that I get into a state of flow is like the piece of paper vanishes, you know, I mean, obviously you should come in prepared enough that if the person's a fucking dud, you can walk them through it.
你对一件你已经知道结果的事情只能保持那么多的兴趣。这是显而易见的。他说，你知道，要灵活，让事情顺其自然。不要试图去操纵它。你知道，可以设定一些目标，但，但，你知道，要真正对可能发生的事情保持开放。我进入心流状态的次数越多，那张纸就越像消失了一样，你知道，我的意思是，显然你应该准备得足够充分，这样如果对方是个烂泥，你也能引导他们完成。
But also be, be soon as you get that green light that there's someone that can run, then you just fucking, yeah, join them, you know, and to that, who do you think maybe you don't want to say, but, but, but can you think of a person who was potentially the biggest surprise in the sense of where you thought it was going to go and where you ended up? Was there one person who stood out to you is like, wow. Yeah. Well, well, well, first and foremost, my mom, that was my favorite interview I've done so far because, you know, she's not, she's not in the public eye.
但也要，一旦你得到绿灯，知道有人可以发挥，那么你就直接，是的，加入他们，你知道，说到这个，你觉得，也许你不想说，但，但，但你能想到一个人，在某种意义上，你以为会往那个方向发展，结果却去了另一个方向，他是最大的惊喜吗？有没有一个人让你觉得，哇。是的。嗯，嗯，嗯，首先，我妈妈，那是我目前为止最喜欢的采访，因为，你知道，她不在公众视野中。
She's never been interviewed and for her to tell her personal stories succinctly and so powerfully was like, I was that, you know, I got to ask her questions in that interview. I never even thought to ask her and then B maybe would have been nervous too, but the time was right and it happened. And so that was, that was like a very profound experience, but dude, dog the bounty hunter, dog the bounty hunter who we all have loved on television. You've seen him run through those doors with the industrial can of mace. He's got his whole, all of his kids or so many kids, you know, the whole thing's great.
她从未接受过采访，她能简洁而有力地讲述她的个人故事，这让我，你知道，我在那次采访中问了她一些问题。我甚至从未想过要问她，而且B可能也会很紧张，但时机对了，事情就发生了。所以那是一次非常深刻的经历，但是伙计，赏金猎人道格（Dog the Bounty Hunter），我们都在电视上喜欢过的赏金猎人道格。你见过他拿着工业级防狼喷雾冲进那些门。他有他的全部，他的很多孩子，你知道，整个事情都很棒。
It's great entertainment. He shows up and dog is got a humongous bandage around his thumb and he has been bit by an actual dog at the Starbucks next to my house minutes ago. So right out of the gates, I'm like dog, dog, the bounty hunter was just bit by a dog. You know, seconds ago and he's here with this, this fucking makeshift bandage. So that already I loved. He came upstairs. His wife had only died three months ago and he just went right at that.
这是很棒的娱乐节目。他出现了，道格的大拇指上缠着一个巨大的绷带，几分钟前他在我家旁边的星巴克被一只真正的狗咬了。所以刚开始，我就想，道格，赏金猎人道格刚刚被狗咬了。你知道，几秒钟前，他带着这个，这个该死的临时绷带出现在这里。所以我已经很喜欢了。他上楼了。他的妻子三个月前才去世，他直接谈到了这一点。
He must have cried six times. I started seeing like, oh, this dude was the sergeant of arms of the devil's disciples motorcycle. That's not Hollywood bullshit or fucking rap stuff. To be the fucking sergeant of arms of the devil's, you've got to kick ass. And I'm looking at this guy and he's the sweetest, most beautiful guy with a fucking terrible stepdad and his whole life is about been building this armor, this outward armor to say, don't hurt me because I will hurt you back.
他一定哭了六次。我开始觉得，哦，这家伙曾经是“恶魔门徒”摩托车帮的军士长。那不是好莱坞的扯淡或该死的说唱东西。要成为“恶魔”的军士长，你必须得是个狠角色。我看着这个家伙，他是最甜美、最可爱的人，有一个该死的糟糕继父，他的一生都在建立这种盔甲，这种外在的盔甲，为了说，别伤害我，因为我会反击。
And I was like, I love you and I relate to you and I'm doing the same thing. I've done the same thing always. And we're all, man, we're all, we've all had babies. You pick them up and they're fucking flawless. And then they just get injured and injured and they create all this stuff to protect themselves. And I just, I don't think I ever felt so, I related so much to a guy as dog, the bounty hunter.
我当时想，我爱你，我与你感同身受，我也一直在做同样的事情。我一直都在做同样的事情。我们所有人，伙计，我们都有过孩子。你抱起他们，他们是完美的。然后他们受伤了，又受伤了，他们创造了所有这些东西来保护自己。我真的觉得我从来没有像对道格，赏金猎人那样，对一个人产生过如此多的共鸣。
Do you still feel like you have that armor? Like do you still feel like you, you put that on to protect yourself? And if so, when do you drop that? I think lesson, lesson, I would, I would credit Kristen with this entirely, which is, you know, for the first Kristen, come on, Sean. No, I know everybody knows. The only reason someone turned into this is to listen to Kristen Bell's husband talk about something.
你现在还觉得你有那种盔甲吗？就像你还觉得你，你穿上它来保护自己吗？如果是这样，你什么时候放下它？我想，教训，教训，我会，我会把这完全归功于克里斯汀（Kristen），也就是，你知道，对于第一个克里斯汀，得了吧，肖恩。不，我知道每个人都知道。有人转变成这样，只是为了听克里斯汀·贝尔（Kristen Bell）的丈夫谈论某事。
So Sean, Sean, Sean, Sean wishes we could have Chyron's on the podcast. Yeah. Yeah. Can I tell you guys one, one funny story about a pamphlets out for it before each episode? Go ahead. Yes, please. Really quick, funny story about Colin Hanks and I about two years ago, I got invited to be a, a judge on a cooking show, right?
所以肖恩，肖恩，肖恩，肖恩希望我们能在播客上用字幕。是的。是的。我能告诉你们一个，一个关于每集之前发传单的有趣故事吗？说吧。是的，请讲。关于我和科林·汉克斯（Colin Hanks）的非常简短的有趣故事，大约两年前，我被邀请去一个烹饪节目当评委，对吧？
And it was a tremendous amount of money for three hours of work. And I said, absolutely. I'll be there. Colin Hanks is the other host. They've got us on the scissor lift. That's got to be four stories high, you guys. And it is so wobbly. They've built like this stage on top of the scissor lift.
那是三个小时的工作，报酬非常丰厚。我说，绝对没问题。我会去的。科林·汉克斯是另一位主持人。他们把我们放在剪叉式升降机上。伙计们，那一定有四层楼高。而且它摇摇晃晃的。他们在剪叉式升降机上面搭了一个舞台。
And then all the chefs are below cooking. And this thing is swaying and rocking. And I say to Colin, I go, I just want you to know when this thing collapse and we die, the headline is going to say Tom Hanks, son and Kristen Bell's husband died in a scissor lift accident. And by the way, it's so, so true, but, but, you know, can I just say this, so like 12 years ago, we do this, we go this funny or die tour that Will Ferrell is doing with. And Adam McKay is like doing the intro stuff for him and Will's performing.
然后所有的厨师都在下面做饭。这东西在摇晃。我对科林说，我说，我只是想让你知道，当这东西倒塌我们死掉的时候，头条新闻会写着：汤姆·汉克斯的儿子和克里斯汀·贝尔的丈夫死于剪叉式升降机事故。顺便说一句，这太，太真实了，但是，但是，你知道，我能说这个吗，就像12年前，我们做这个，我们参加了威尔·法瑞尔（Will Ferrell）做的那个“搞笑或死亡”（Funny or Die）巡演。亚当·麦凯（Adam McKay）在为他做开场介绍，威尔在表演。
And then he's got a couple of standups and one of them is Gal Finakis and who else? A bunch of guys doing Nick Swartzson and stuff. And Adam, Adam had to leave the tour for like a week. He got sick. And Will, we were doing pro promo for this thing and he goes, come with us. You're leaving. We're leaving tonight and you're coming. You're filling in for McKay for a week.
然后他有几个单口喜剧演员，其中一个是加里·加利费安纳基斯（Galifianakis），还有谁？一堆人在做尼克·斯沃茨森（Nick Swartzson）之类的东西。亚当，亚当不得不离开巡演一周。他病了。威尔，我们当时在为这个做宣传，他说，跟我们一起去。你要离开。我们今晚就走，你也要来。你要替麦凯一周。
I was like, great, it'll be super fun. So we go to like Penn State and we go to, we go to University of Rhode Island. There's like 20,000 people in the, in these arenas that feels great. And I, Will goes out, he does the intro as first. And I'm just kind of his sidekick on the side of the stage, helping him keep it moving. We get to Boston, Boston College and it's, blah, blah, blah, blah. And he's like, oh, we're so happy to have you. And here he is coming out.
我说，太棒了，那会超级有趣。所以我们去了宾夕法尼亚州立大学，我们去了罗德岛大学。这些竞技场里有大约20,000人，感觉太棒了。威尔走出去，他先做介绍。我只是他在舞台侧面的搭档，帮他保持节奏。我们到了波士顿，波士顿学院，然后是，等等等等。他说，哦，我们很高兴有你。他来了。
You love him. Here he is. Amy Polar's husband. And I come out of here and I'm like, in front of all 20,000 people, I'm like, you son of a bitch. That's hilarious. Polar's husband. That's funny.
你爱他。他来了。艾米·波勒（Amy Poehler）的丈夫。我走出来，在所有20,000人面前，我说，你这个狗娘养的。太搞笑了。波勒的丈夫。那很有趣。
Anyway. But anyways, yeah, so, so Bell had, you know, we, we one time were on actress, Kristen Bell. Princess Anna, Kristen Bell, what if, what if she didn't even earn her own title, either? So we're on our way to this place and we'd been together for maybe a year and we're dressed up and a guy threw this humongous drink at my windshield in my car. No. On sunset.
总之。但无论如何，是的，所以，所以贝尔有，你知道，我们，我们有一次在女演员克里斯汀·贝尔那里。安娜公主，克里斯汀·贝尔，如果，如果她甚至没有赢得自己的头衔呢？所以我们在去那个地方的路上，我们在一起可能有一年了，我们打扮得很漂亮，一个家伙把这杯巨大的饮料扔到了我车的挡风玻璃上。不。在日落大道上。
Yeah. Right in front of Chateau. He was hammered and he was like crossing sunset in front of Chateau. There's no crosswalk there. He had plenty of fucking time. I didn't slow down. So then he realized I wasn't slowing down. So then he was like tough guy in it, just standing in the middle of the road.
是的。就在城堡酒店（Chateau）前面。他喝醉了，他就像在城堡酒店前面穿过日落大道。那里没有斑马线。他有足够的时间。我没有减速。所以他意识到我没有减速。所以他就表现得像个硬汉，站在路中间。
So then I went by him on the outside. He chucked this huge drink. I thought the windshield had exploded because it was just, you know, glass and ice everywhere. And I thought the windshield was blown out. So that, that thing exploded and the e-brake was up and I was exiting the vehicle before the car was stopped and I fought this guy on the sidewalk and, you know, he was screaming, I'll sue you and the whole people at that magazine stand were like looking and they missed the part where he fucking threw a glass at my car.
所以我从外侧绕过他。他扔了这杯巨大的饮料。我以为挡风玻璃炸开了，因为到处都是玻璃和冰。我以为挡风玻璃被炸飞了。所以那东西炸开了，手刹拉着，我在车停下之前就下了车，我在人行道上和这个家伙打了一架，你知道，他尖叫着，我要起诉你，那个杂志摊的所有人都看着，他们错过了他把玻璃扔到我车上的那部分。
So it looked, it literally looked like I was just beating the fuck out of a random guy on the sidewalk. So no jaywalking. Yes. Vigilante jaywalk enforcers. So I get back in the car in my hunches that she didn't love that. You know, I know enough that that wasn't great for her. But God bless her.
所以看起来，字面上看起来就像我只是在人行道上暴打一个随机的家伙。所以不要乱穿马路。是的。义务警员乱穿马路执法者。所以我回到车里，我的直觉是她不喜欢那样。你知道，我知道得足够多，那对她来说不太好。但上帝保佑她。
She didn't say a thing and we get to this restaurant. It was right before the Soho house opened, but they had it, you know, running and she and I had hurt my leg pretty bad because when I kicked him, I hit his head on my shin and I had a huge egg on my, on my shin and, and she was aware of it and I was kind of limping as we got out of the valet. And so she said she had to go to the bathroom. She came back and she had procured me like a bag of ice and slid it to me under the table. This is like a meeting with her representatives.
她什么也没说，我们到了那家餐厅。那是在Soho House开业之前，但他们已经让它运行了，她和我，我的腿伤得很重，因为当我踢他时，我用我的胫骨撞到了他的头，我的胫骨上有一个巨大的包，她注意到了，我们下代客泊车时我有点跛。所以她说她要去洗手间。她回来时，她为我弄了一袋冰，在桌子底下递给我。这就像是和她的代表开会。
There's other actors there and she's sliding me a bag of ice for my leg that I kicked somebody with. And, you know, afterwards we had a talk about it and I said, you know, thanks for not running me up the flagpole. I shouldn't have done that, blah, blah, blah. And she said, why do you do that? And I said, you know, I, I have a bully thing and I have a, I'm going to protect everyone thing and I, and I will never be a victim again.
那里还有其他演员，她正在给我递一袋冰，为了我踢人的那条腿。而且，你知道，事后我们谈了谈，我说，你知道，谢谢你没有把我挂在旗杆上。我不该那样做，等等等等。她说，你为什么要那样做？我说，你知道，我，我有一种欺凌倾向，我有一种我要保护每个人的倾向，而且我永远不会再成为受害者。
I have all this stuff and she said, you know, I just want you to know it doesn't make me feel safer that you'll stand up for me. It makes me feel more scared. Like when we go places, I'm afraid you're going to be punching people. And I was like, wow, that's the opposite outcome of what I'm trying to do. Like I want you to know that I will fucking go through 10 guys if they're saying something to you. And she's like, yeah, that just doesn't make me feel safe.
我有所有这些东西，她说，你知道，我只是想让你知道，你为我挺身而出并不会让我觉得更安全。这让我觉得更害怕。就像我们去某些地方时，我害怕你会打人。我当时想，哇，那和我试图做的结果完全相反。就像我想让你知道，如果有人对你说什么，我会该死地冲过去对付10个人。她说，是的，那并不能让我觉得安全。
And I was like, well, this is, I've been telling myself a lie. No one feels safer around me. You don't feel safer. You're waiting for me to get into some shit sometimes. I think it's funny. I love it when you mix it up with others. There've been a few times, a few times where I was, where Dax, like basically big brother did it for me, which is unbelievably great.
我当时想，好吧，这是，我一直在对自己撒谎。没有人觉得在我身边更安全。你并不觉得更安全。你有时在等我惹上什么麻烦。我觉得这很有趣。我喜欢你和别人发生冲突的时候。有几次，有几次，达克斯（Dax），就像大哥一样为我做了这件事，这真是太棒了。
Dax, how often when you're out driving around in Los Angeles, are you driving aggressively, taking risks, breaking laws, you know, not, not, not, not being irresponsible, but getting after it. This is so embarrassing to say, but 100% of the time, I'm like the wolf in, in, in Pulp Fiction. Like it's 20 minutes away. I'll see you in eight minutes. My, my hobby in life is getting that way.
达克斯，当你开车在洛杉矶四处转悠时，你多久会开得很有侵略性，冒险，违反法律，你知道，不是，不是，不是不负责任，而是全力以赴。说出来太尴尬了，但100%的时间，我就像《低俗小说》里的那个“狼”。就像还有20分钟的路程。我8分钟后见你。我生活中的爱好就是那样。
I have that same bad habit. Yeah. I get that ways estimate of how long it's going to take me. And for me, if I don't beat that by 20%, I should throw my car keys in the trash. I'm exactly, I'm exactly the same way. I live my life exactly the same way. I see that estimate and to me, it says you're a fucking coward if it takes, it's like, it's like, it's like name that tune.
我有同样的坏习惯。是的。我得到了关于需要多长时间的估计。对我来说，如果我不能比那个时间快20%，我就应该把车钥匙扔进垃圾桶。我完全，我完全一样。我过着完全一样的生活。我看到了那个估计，对我来说，它说如果你花了那么长时间，你就是个该死的懦夫。这就像，这就像，这就像猜歌名。
I'll beat that. I'll beat that two minutes. I can beat that in one minute. I told you this, we talked about it when I was on your show, but two, two of the guys on this house, you and Bateman are the only two people that I know even in my life now that if I get in a car that I'm okay if they're driving, you two guys are the only guys. Sean, you and I haven't driven enough to, no, I'm pretty, I'm pretty bad. Max, wouldn't you love to do a remake of Against All Odds and do that race on Sunset with James
我会打败那个。我会打败那两分钟。我可以在一分钟内打败它。我告诉过你这个，当我在你的节目上时我们谈过，但这个房子的两个人，你和贝特曼（Bateman）是我生活中唯一我知道的，如果我上了一辆车，如果他们开车我没问题，你们两个是唯一的人。肖恩，你和我开车开得不够多，不，我挺，我挺糟糕的。马克斯，你不想翻拍《Against All Odds》并在日落大道上和詹姆斯·伍兹（James Woods）和杰夫·布里吉斯（Jeff Bridges）做那场比赛吗？
Woods and Jeff Bridges did? Bateman, remember, I told you, I wrote that, the Daryl Hall show, right, that I was, I sold the show time. It was, it was a false history of Daryl Hall's life. Hall and Oats. Yeah, it's a great idea. Really? And I was going to play Daryl Hall and then the whole, the whole world's fake.
贝特曼，记得吗，我告诉过你，我写了那个，达里尔·霍尔（Daryl Hall）的节目，对吧，我把它卖给了Showtime。那是，那是达里尔·霍尔生活的虚假历史。霍尔与奥兹（Hall and Oates）。是的，这是个好主意。真的吗？我本来要演达里尔·霍尔，然后整个，整个世界都是假的。
Like you find out all the, the real meanings behind all those hit songs and it's just insanity. God, if you could get Schwarzman in a, in a perm to do Oats, God, whatever happened with that because I remember you telling me about that. It ended up getting really dicey with Daryl's giving us life rights. So I became friends with him and he's awesome guy and understandably he was nervous about about, you know, I'm telling a history of his life, but it's all insane. But Bateman in the fucking pilot shot for shot the Against All Odds races in there in the same cars up Sunset.
就像你发现了所有那些热门歌曲背后的真实含义，这简直是疯了。天哪，如果你能让施瓦茨曼（Schwarzman）烫个头来演奥兹，天哪，那件事后来怎么样了，因为我记得你跟我说过。最后和达里尔的生活权搞得很棘手。所以我成了他的朋友，他是个很棒的家伙，可以理解他很紧张，关于，你知道，我讲述他生活的历史，但这都很疯狂。但贝特曼，在那个该死的试播集里，逐个镜头地拍了《Against All Odds》的比赛，在同一辆车里，沿着日落大道。
It's literally, I wrote it, I wrote it and I was, my whole fantasy is like, I cannot wait to reshoot that fucking piece. Do you think you'd ever be able to permit that, like get sunset locked down so you could shoot that? No way, right? Oh, it's so easy. Dude, it's so easy. A true story.
这字面上是，我写的，我写的，我的整个幻想是，我等不及要重拍那个该死的片段了。你觉得你有可能获准那样做吗，比如把日落大道封锁起来，这样你就可以拍摄了？不可能，对吧？哦，太容易了。伙计，太容易了。一个真实的故事。
We, we developed a pilot, Thoreau and I developed a pilot for Don Johnson playing like, Justin Thoreau. Justin Thoreau. Playing a sort of. Jennifer Aniston's ex-husband. Yeah. That's right. With, for Don Johnson, Tubs' partner, we do a thing where he plays this guy, he's kind
我们，我们开发了一个试播集，梭罗（Thoreau）和我开发了一个试播集，让唐·约翰逊（Don Johnson）扮演，贾斯汀·梭罗（Justin Thoreau）。贾斯汀·梭罗。扮演一个类似。詹妮弗·安妮斯顿（Jennifer Aniston）的前夫。是的。没错。和，为唐·约翰逊，塔布斯（Tubs）的搭档，我们做了一件事，他扮演这个家伙，他有点像克罗克特（Crockett），但后来，这是一个很棒的角色，但我们有整个片段是完全逐个镜头地穿过贝弗利格伦（Beverly Glen）和日落大道的交叉口，他在那里冲过去。Against All Odds。Against All Odds。该死。所有的路都回到了《Against All Odds》。我们能告诉大家我们的DJ故事吗，这是我最喜欢的演艺圈故事之一。
of like a Crockett, but later in, it was a great part, but we had this whole segment was the exact shot for shot through the intercession of Beverly Glen and Sunset where he blows through. Against All Odds. Against All Odds. God damn. All roads lead back to Against All Odds. Can we tell everyone our DJ story, which is one of my favorite show business stories
永远。唐·约翰逊。阿内特（Arnett）。所以阿内特和我正在和唐·约翰逊拍一部电影，有几件有趣的事情。唐，看，我喜欢《迈阿密风云》（Miami Vice），唐·约翰逊很棒，但我不是唐·约翰逊的忠实粉丝，但阿内特是，去他的。他是他的，乔·纳马斯（Joe Namath），迈克尔·乔丹。看看他。
ever. Don Johnson. Arnett. So Arnett and I are doing a movie with Don Johnson and a couple of funny things. Don, look, I loved Miami Vice in Don Johnson's awesome, but I'm not a devotee of Don Johnson, but Arnett is, fuck it. He is his, Joe Namath, Michael Jordan. Look at him.
这越界了。他太激动了，唐·约翰逊竟然降临了。就像我们在意大利，他一直在更新DJ什么时候会到。他太激动了，对吧？所以阿内特在他到达的那一秒起就给了他真正的全场紧逼。唐很亲切，很好，但即使是你也会承认阿内特，他有点像，好吧，伙计。然后我有点，我对待他像，我表现得太强烈了。
It's over the line. He is so thrilled that Don Johnson has landed. Like we're in Italy and he's like getting updates when DJ is going to arrive. He's so thrilled, right? And so Arnett gives him a real full court press from the second he arrives. And Don is cordial and nice, but even you would admit Arnett, he's a little bit like, all right, bud. And then I'm kind of, I'm treating him like, I came on way too strong.
哦，该死，你，是的，当你冲过来的时候，大门甚至还没开。所以，我当时给了他，你知道，你是学校里最火的女孩的待遇。所以我忽略了他，他不是对我着迷了吗，嗯，阿内特？他就像，我想要你翻拍。他说，如果他们真的翻拍我的关于成为他的电影，我被激怒了。我该死的，我很有钱，他怎么敢，达克斯甚至不在乎。这太棒了。
Oh, fucking, you, yeah, the gates weren't even open when you were springing. And so, and I was kind of giving them the, you know, you're the hottest girl in school treatment. And so I was ignoring him and didn't he become obsessed with me, huh, Arnett? He was like, I want you to do a remake. He's like, if they ever do a remake of mine about being him, and I'm incensed. I'm fucking, I'm rich at how dare he, Dax doesn't even care. It's so great.
然后，所以有一次我们在拍那个场景时，场景是，我们都在教堂参加婚礼，阿内特和我坐在唐·约翰逊后面一排。这个镜头是唐·约翰逊的，但在那个场景之前，DJ把我拉到一边，因为现在他在指导我，他说，你知道我是怎么在《迈阿密风云》中与观众建立联系的吗？我的诀窍是什么。我说，不，你会怎么做？他说，我嗡嗡镜头，每集至少一次，嗡嗡镜头。
And then so at one point while we're shooting the scene, and the scene is, we're all in a church at a wedding and Arnett and I are one pew behind Don Johnson. And this shot is of Don Johnson, but just prior to this scene, DJ pulls me aside because now he's mentoring me and he says, you know how I connected with the audience on Miami Vice? What my trick was. And I go, no, what would you do? And he goes, I buzz the lens, at least once in episode, buzz the lens.
我说，等等，你会直接看向摄像机的镜头筒。他说，哦，是的，你只是瞥一眼，你嗡嗡镜头，你跳进去，然后你出来。那，那对他来说，就是《迈阿密风云》成功的秘诀。所以我立刻告诉了阿内特，我们对此笑得前仰后合。就在下一个镜头，可怜的DJ，他在前景里拼命地演戏。我假设那些在，在他肩膀的两侧，直接看向该死的镜头。
I go, hold on, you would look right down the barrel of the camera. And he goes, oh yeah, just you glance it, you buzz the lens, you pop in and then you're out. And that, that for him, that was the recipe for success on Miami Vice. So I immediately tell Arnett this, we're in stitches about it. The very next take, poor DJ, he's acting his ass off in the foreground. I suppose those are about on the other, on either side of his shoulders, looking right in the fucking lens.
我的意思是，我们是目标锁定盯着。那感觉太疯狂了，因为你知道，你所有的训练都是永远不要看那个镜头，我们直视了大约六分钟，现在我们笑得太厉害了。我们就像，我们在捏对方的腿，我们试图不笑场，我们只是在镜头里，它竟然真的被剪进去了。这是有史以来最伟大的拍摄日之一。这是什么电影？
I mean, we are target lot staring. It was the craziest feeling because you know, you're all your trainings that never look at that lens and we were straight in it for like six minutes and now we're laughing so hard. We're like, we're squeezing each other's legs and we're trying not to bust and we're just in the lens and it made the fucking cut. It's one of the greatest days of filming ever. What is this film?
哦，天哪。《罗马情缘》（When in Rome）。克里斯汀·贝尔。我们稍后再谈那个。没错。那不是重点。其实，你知道吗，问一个好的脚注是，DJ和我后来成了好朋友。
Oh boy. When in Rome. Kristen Bell. We'll tie that up later. That's right. That's not the point. Actually, you know what, to ask a good footnote to that is that DJ and I have since become good pals.
我就知道。当然。我磨垮了他。你玩了长线游戏。他提起过我吗？当然。那种方式。当然。
I knew it. Of course. I wore him down. You played the long game. Does he ever bring me up? Of course. The one that kind of way. Of course.
当然他会。你是他无法停止想念的前任。哦，伙计。我确实爱他。他该死的太棒了。他真是个酷家伙。然后我们拿了，嗡嗡镜头，我们就照做了。你知道吗，从那以后，我几乎在我做过的每一件事上都说过。
Of course he does. You're the ex he can't stop thinking about. Oh man. I did love him. He's fucking awesome. He's such a cool dude. And then we took, buzzed the lens and we just ran with it. You know what, I've said it on virtually everything I've ever done since then.
我一直在谈论嗡嗡镜头。我从你那里听到过。是的。我喜欢时不时地抓一点玻璃。我想到了DJ。只是那种看。达克斯，你过去总是说，我喜欢直接对着镜头投一个快球。当然。
I've always talked about buzzing the lens. I have heard that from you. Yeah. I like to grab a little glass every now and then. I think a DJ. Just kind of look. Dax, you used to always say, I like to throw a fastball right down the lens. Sure.
直接对着镜头筒。达克斯，在我们结束之前，因为我不想占用你太多时间，为了你建立的帝国。是的。顺便说一句，如果克里斯汀厌倦了你的垃圾，给我打电话。好的。我觉得你很棒。好的，太棒了。
Right in the barrel. Dax, as we wrap up, because I don't want to take too much of your time for your empire that you've built. Yeah. And let me say as an aside, if Kristen ever gets sick of your garbage, call me. Okay. I think you're swell. Okay, great.
我觉得你真的很棒。哦，等等。你会要我。是的，我会要你。你会要她。是的，不，不，不。我会派阿曼达（Amanda）去克里斯汀家。那会很棒。
I think you're real swell. Oh, wait. You'll take me. Yeah, I'll take you. You'll take her. Yeah, no, no, no. I'll send Amanda over to Kristen's house. It'll be great.
然后我们会去滑雪旅行。我得。别让他带你去滑雪旅行。是的。带我去滑雪旅行。因为我们要做的就是往北走。我们要去猛犸山（Mammoth）。然后我们要前往。
And we'll go on a ski trip. I got to. Don't let him get you on a ski trip. Yeah. Get me on a ski trip. Because what we'll do is we'll go north. We'll go to Mammoth. And then we'll head on up to.
我们来了。所以395，美国395号公路。是的，没错。在太阳谷（Sun Valley）。然后我们要把它带到杰克逊（Jackson）。哦。但达克斯，我们为你在这个，在这个我们只是在一点点努力的世界里取得的成功感到非常自豪。
Here we go. So 395, US 395. Yeah, yup. Up in the Sun Valley. Then we're going to take it over to Jackson. Oh. But Dax, we are so proud of you for your success in this, in this kind of world that we're just kind of chipping away at.
我们确实仰望你，并非常荣幸你今天加入我们。而且这也是我们最亲密的朋友之一。但作为这个我们一无所知的世界的导师。所以希望我们能，我们能向你学习。我们非常爱你，谢谢你抽出时间和你繁忙的日程。我知道你要接管世界了。所以我爱你，达克斯。
And we do look up to you and are so honored that you joined us today. And that also is one of our closest friends. But as a mentor to this world, we know nothing about. And so hopefully we can, we can learn from you. And we love you so much. And thank you for taking the time and your busy schedule. I know you're taking over the world. So I love you Dax.
爱你们。爱你们，达克斯。谢谢伙计。再见，达克斯。向克里斯汀问好。这永远，永远不会过时。不，他是最好的。你知道，天哪，他太开放了，一点也不害怕脆弱，什么都说。
Love you guys. Love you Daxie. Thanks buddy. Bye Daxels. Say hi to Kristen. It never, ever gets old. No, he's the best. You know, my God, he's so open and so not afraid to be vulnerable and everything.
我的意思是，我不知道他还有什么没透露的。是的。而且这也不是演戏。这是完全真诚的。你可以看出他真的很喜欢现在的自己。他真的对自己很自在。他一直都有令人难以置信的魅力，但我认为他说他从来没有更好过，或者自从他和克里斯汀在一起后，她让他变得更好了。
I mean, I don't know what he hasn't revealed. Yeah. And it's not a bit either. It's completely sincere. You can tell he really likes who he is. He's truly comfortable in his skin. He's always had incredible charisma, but I think he said that he's never been better or that since he's been with Kristen, she's made him better.
他确实，他过去很棒。但即使是现在他只是，我是真诚的。我希望他感觉到我是真诚的，当我说，如果事情和他不顺利的话。当然。他可以给我打电话。他是个如此真实的人。我应该留下我的号码。我不知道。
And he truly, he was great back in the day. But even now he's just, I was sincere. I hope he felt that I was sincere when I said, if things don't work out with him. Of course. That he can call me. He's such an authentic guy. I should have left my number. I don't know.
但他是个如此真实的人。我认为你们可能会同意我的一点是，我们认识他很多年了，你看着他，他在那段时间里经历了不同的阶段，但他总是对他所处的位置非常诚实，无论他在哪里。总是。这太棒了。总是。我想这就是为什么，这就是为什么他成功了。
But he's such an authentic guy. One of the things I think that you guys will probably agree with me on is we've known him for a number of years and you see him, he's gone through different stages in that time, but he's always been really honest about where he's at, wherever it is that he's at. Always. That's so great. Always. And I think that's why, that's why he's successful.
是的。现在我们看到他处于这个位置，你可以看出他是真的快乐。所以我们，你相信它，因为它是真的。这不是演戏。这不是表演。他找到了一个真正拥抱并利用他最好品质的媒介和形式。我为他感到激动。很棒的嘉宾，肖恩。
Yeah. Now we see him in this place and you can see that he is truly happy. So we, you believe it because it's true. It's not a bit. It's not an act. And he's found a medium and a format that truly embraces and takes advantage of his best qualities. I'm thrilled for him. Great guess, Sean.
谢谢。干得好，肖恩。好吧，那么，下次见。和你聊天很愉快。明天见。哦，我喜欢那个。和你聊天很愉快。
Thank you. Nice going, Sean. All right. Well, until next time. Nice potting with you. See you tomorrow. Oh, I like that. Nice potting with you.
聊天很愉快。好的。再见大家。再见你们。太有趣了。爱你们。爱你们。再见。
Nice potting. Okay. Bye everybody. Bye you guys. So much fun. Love you guys. Love you guys. Bye.
再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
Bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击逐字稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。